l'interview je suis habillé en rose la
perception vous avez deux mois et pas du
tout la même que si j'étais habillé en
bleu aussi j'étais habillé en vert
[Musique]
en angleterre on a repeint des salles de
classe qui était belge des salles de
classes d'enfants de 7 8 ans elle a
repeint en rose et on a comparé les
dessins des enfants avant et depuis que
ces salles de classe sont roses et on se
rend compte que depuis que ces salles de
classe ont 7 7 couleurs les desserts les
enfants sont beaucoup plus positif
il ya des soleils plus marqué moins de
nuages etc tu as vraiment une différence
incroyable entre le avant et le après
pourquoi personne le sévère que ce qui
est d'un point de vue scientifique le
rose et le rouge c'est la même longueur
d'onde
donc comment se fait-il qu on ait des
influences quasi opposé entre le rose et
le rouge
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas un scientifique
sur terre qui est capable de répondre à
cette question mais ce qui est
formidable c'est que tu as des centaines
de scientifiques partout dans le monde
qui travaillent sur ces influences parce
qu'elle se rende compte que que ça va
vraiment très très loin sur notre moral
sur notre productivité en médecine du
travail par exemple on se rend compte
aujourd'hui que le pire du pire du pire
c'est les murs blancs parce que quand tu
as des murs blancs dans ton bureau tu as
un risque de burn out supérieur une
productivité qui est pas terrible
tu t'ennuies tu es moins créatif la pire
des couleurs dans lequel on puisse
travailler c'est donc du blanc or
aujourd'hui à peu près huit personnes
sur dix sont des bureaux blanc en tout
cas en france
quand tu es en rouge tu es un leader si
tu es habillée en rouge on se rend
compte que tu que tu es vraiment
quelqu'un qui en impose si tu regardes
bien les hommes politiques souvent on
des cravates rouges prendre 30 qui se
prend pour le maître du monde il a
souvent sa cravate rouge
on le voit dans le sport par exemple on
a compilé tous les matchs de lutte
gréco-romaine tus élus locaux romaine
tués soit avec un maillot bleu soit avec
un maillot rouge depuis le début des
jeux olympiques modernes
on est à plus de deux tiers de victoire
pour le lutteur habillé en rouge
pourquoi parce que quand tu es en rouge
tu te prends pour un chef des toiles ont
tourné demi ton adversaire tu te fait
moins peur l'adversaire qui est en bleu
te vois en rouge dit oulala celui-là il
va être fort et l'arbitré aussi a le
sentiment que le plus fort c'est celui
qui est habillé en rouge
alors attention si tu te mets en rouge
au tennis tu battra pas là rafael nadal
ça se joue à pas grand-chose mais le
fait d'être en rouge
ça te donne une force incroyable si tu
regardes le verre est il exactement au
milieu entre les infrarouges les
ultraviolets c'est vraiment la couleur
au centre c'est la couleur de l'
équilibre et on va le retrouver dans
plein plein plein de domaines à las
vegas par exemple on a fait jouer des
joueurs sur des tapis à la roulette des
tapis bleu rouge ou verte
quand les tapis sont rouges les joueurs
jouent fortement mais se lasse très vite
quand les tapis sont bleus ils vont
jouer mollement mais puissent s'ennuyer
donc ils vont pas pas joué beaucoup
quand les tapis sont verts eelv ont joué
modérément mais même s'il commence à
perdre ils vont continuer à jouer parce
que cette couleur va redonner confiance
et ils vont se dire je vais me refaire
quand tu demandes aux personnes quelle
ce cas quel est votre couleur préférée
il ya très peu de gens qui répondent le
jaune
et quand on vous quand tu dis quelle est
la couleur que tu aimes le moins
beaucoup de gens n'aiment pas le jaune
bleu et vert situé dans un bureau bleu
tu vas avoir de meilleures idées tu vas
mieux travailler tu veux c'est vraiment
une très très bonne couleur pour tous
ceux qui travaillent qui ont des travaux
20 des métiers créatifs
je vous conseille le bleu ou le verre
c'est une coup c'est incroyable les
bonnes idées on les trouve dans du bleu
dans du verre par contre on est moins
productif
on sera moins précis en fait plus de
fautes d'orthographe que si on est dans
du rouge de laurent joue du jaune
d'ailleurs un petit conseil moi ce que
je fais je vous conseille d'essayer et y
ait plusieurs fonds d'écran et selon les
tâches que vous faites changer la
couleur de votre fond d'écran parce que
c'est pas toujours évident de lire votre
patron gens viennent vous repeignez les
murs de mon bureau
donc commencer par votre fond d'écran
quand vous avez besoin d'être concentré
où vous êtes un peu fatigué va falloir
faire une journée de 12 heures
mettez-vous avec un fond d'écran rouge
vous travaillerez 12 heures si vous avez
bien de trouver la bonne idée
mettez-vous avec un fond d'écran bleu ou
vert est certainement vous avez plus de
chances de la trouver